since we're talking about sci-fi uh you
know we can elaborate on I mean I
personally think that anthr robots or
other
synthetic uh living biological tissues
can if you can scale them up could even
you be used for um like construction
like for actual inhabitable structures
so I actually have a background in
architecture um and what really brought
me into this field of um that's
interesting yeah I mean I recognize is
that um in biology there is this um
ability to embod you know um self-c
construct with um sort of this embodied
morphogenetic code and as Mike was
talking about the this comes in layers
we're often sort of conditioned maybe
from you know middle school biology
classes to think about DNA as the rule
book for everything but what we're
discovering um is that yes gentic the
code is important but there are
additional layers um you know there's
epigenetics or bi bi electricity that
together make up this morphogenetic code
and how can we edit this code to steer
um these um cells into completely new
architectures that never existed before
whether to use it um either to use it in
medicine in these ways that we're
talking about or again since we're
talking about sci-fi I'm personally
interested in scaling this up um into
building like self-constructing bricks
and then you know by using those bricks
can we build living architectures
because um you know yeah I mean when you
look at um the you know global warming
like more than 40% of the CO2 release to
the environment is coming from the
construction industry just trying to
like build things yes yes and that's
using the knowledge that we have
developed as humans for thousands of
year years in the field of Art
architecture civil engineering but at
the same time when you look at nature
it's also able to build um structures at
at scale like oak trees or um a lot of
you know like you see a whale and a
biology can build you know large things
um without let alone releasing carbon
but by sucking carbon from the
environment so it's literally carbon
negative the exact opposite of what we
are um doing as humans um and now like
in the you know 21st century we're
learning that that's actually also
programmable it's not set in stone
you're not limited to only what's
evolved out there but as a biologist
engineer designer you can actually edit
nature and create new structures so why
not create structures that we can use to
solve some of the other problems um like
sustainable construction yeah or even
space exploration I mean right now it's
real difficult to leave the planet um
because of the gravitational pull so the
more weight you have you know aboard in
your spacecraft the more you're being
pulled back you need to have larger
Rockets to get you out but then those
Rockets also uh pull you down even more
because of their weight and you know um
intricate balance and are you really
going to put in a bunch of like dead
weight like bricks um you know um or
concrete um precursors to build in like
outer space instead instead can you just
take a tube of engineered cells that
weigh nothing and then once you leave
the gravitational pole you can just grow
them up into new structures that you can
use to you know build in um in outer
space so you look at a lot to medicine
but I think there applications in other
fields too right that's super cool so
gazm you don't know this but my
background is in math and physics and I
often wonder what would I do if I had to
do it over and I had to choose something
else what would I choose and I think it
would be civil engineering well I often
say this because I look at houses and
how they're constructed and it looks the
same as it's looked for the past few
decades and it takes just as long and I
always think man I wish that that could
be done much quicker I'm also a
germaphobe so in addition to being
mathematical physics there's germaphobia
and I'm a nerd so Dragon Ball Z and
Dragon Ball Z I don't know if you know
this show but you have this little
capsule you bring with you and then you
throw it on the ground and it becomes a
house or it becomes whatever yeah so
that's really the dream yes I like this
idea of building a robot from smaller
pieces because like I'm a germaphobe and
I want robots to clean washrooms I just
feel horrible for janitors I feel like
oh my gosh like how do they do that and
they should be paid so much more I wish
a robot could just go and do that and
then a robot would deconstruct because
then you'd wonder how do you clean the
robot Yeah by a degrade yeah so I hope
that you could make some inroads
there yeah I mean we have micr fases
that go down like Chase bacteria and
swallow it and degrade it so we can
maybe transfer the same principles to
biobots what's the lifespan or
functional lifespan of the anobot that
you've been studying uh so yeah um so
the for them to build themselves it's
about two weeks um and then for this um
so we at the very beginning talked about
uh releasing them from the Matrix and
then having them sort of turn inside out
that morphological reorganization that
takes sort of another week or so so
three weeks is for their developmental
um developmental phase which we now work
we're working on a follow-up paper to
characterize those stages more but once
it's a sort of adult bot that is able to
move around um we there is a variability
there um we've seen them living from
sort of month to multiple months but
what happens in every single case um if
you know in their V if you're not like
giving them different um drugs or
anything in their vile type androbot
case what happens at the end of the
these multi-month um period is every
single time just degradation into
individual cells so um and and to debris
so they're able to naturally biodegrade
um which sort of helps with the concerns
around well if you put them into body
then what's going to happen will they
ever like create clogs we what we have
seen in the lab is every single time
they degrade into individual cells so
then that's not going to be any
different than individual cells that
your body disposes
of now I understand you didn't
genetically modify
but did you observe any other changes
that were epigenetic or
bioelectric uh we haven't looked at
there electricity as Mike said that's
like definitely one of the next things
to look at because there's so much there
and that was that concept concept was
foreign to me until I came to Mike lab
uh up until uh my PhD I was doing a lot
of actually gentic editing synthetic
circuits to change morphology and it was
here that I'm realizing that there are
all these other layers like the complete
morphogenetic code so no that that's not
something we've done yet but we would
love to look at um but other EP
epigenetic so I mean this whole thing um
that we talked at the beginning about
character formation right so none no two
anobot are identical but we have these
morphotypes and behavioral classes that
also happen to influence each other uh
so figures 2 3 4 in the paper um I mean
that has got to be um a result of some
sort of epigenetic influence because
again every single anobot starts with
the exact same DNA but they end up in
different um sort of morphological
flavors one is fully covered with cyia
one sort of morphotype another
morphotype um is fully polarized so half
of it is covered with Celia the other
half is bold the third type is um again
Celia everywhere but much more part so
like a checkerboard pattern I mean if
all of these Bots have started with the
same DNA what's causing this
morphological you know um variability
and that has got to be
epigenetics uh we don't yet know uh what
those epigenetic knobs are uh we have
some supplementary um data in the paper
that um discuss matri gel The Matrix
viscosity as a potential factor or they
um initial you know cell density so
that's sort of reminisent of Angela's
work like based on how many cells we
start with the
resulting um an population profile is
different so those are the only two
things we've looked at and we have SE
statistically significant differences so
those seem to be like maybe one of the
first couple knobs but we still have a
long way to understand what are the
knobs and then uh what's the underlying
sort of mechanism that's making those
knobs to be the ones that are
influential yeah one one one thing that
I just wanted to add um on top of that
is that um the original meaning of the
word epigenetics was basically
everything that's not the genome right
so so that includes bioelectricity that
right so so traditionally that would
include biophysical factors
biomechanical factors um ionic factors
and so on so when we say um at least
when I say epigenetic I don't just mean
the chromatin modifications that people
focus on today you know the methylation
the cation all that stuff but actually
all these other things so so we don't
know I mean there could be of course
there could be chromatin modification
effects but but we are you know the next
step is is to look at the at the
bioelectrics and and probably
biomechanics too and other other um
aspects of the physiology of it so there
was a term gazm that was used and
Michael I'd like you to explain it just
for the audience to know it was Matrix
and the term Escaping The Matrix was
used and so because we're dealing with
people thinking you've cracked the code
you need to explain what's meant by that
because people are going to think
everyone here is 95 years old and you
just made yourselves look younger that's
right it's the cosmic Matrix no it's not
the cosmic matrix it's um yeah so so so
cells produce this stuff called
extracellular Matrix and it's basically
just a uh it's a collection of important
molecules that sit on the outside of
cells and between cells and they uh they
it has all sorts of functions including
as a repository for information so much
like ants um leave leave each other
messages in their environment right and
it's of thing called stigmergy when you
can when you use the environment as a
scratch Pad so uh extracellular Matrix
in Vivo is this kind of like um Rich set
of molecules that are hanging out
between and outside of cells that can
also be used as information and and
influence and so uh G giz she could tell
you more about the the specifics of it
but but she's she's using a specific um
Matrix to support these cells in their
journey to becoming an answer by if you
enjoyed that clip then the full podcast
is out right now you can click around
here enjoy subscribe to theories of
everything to get notified of upcoming
podcasts as there are new full length
podcasts every week on the topics of
mathematics physics Consciousness Free
Will and
AI